was devastated at the loss of her
brother
some cousin frenzies got first amount of
friends will devastated to her but that
the mishap we don't actually know what
has actually happened I suppose that is
what is the most brilliant thing for us
at the moment is nobody's actually come
forward and told us this is what has
taken place whether we believe what
they're saying or whether we don't this
should be somebody here put in my
parents mind at rest about what is
actually going on I said all families
devastated about one part mot portrayed
as some kind of gangster is a family man
as you see from the true pictures that
you will see of him there what do you
say to the allegation that a police
officer was shot at rubbish I think it's
rubbish my brother's not that sort of
person he's not stupid to shoot after
the police that's ridiculous what do you
say to anyone who seeks to go and create
scenes like that in your brother's name
we're not couldn't over in any kind of
actions right at all to be shown Oh or
for this to be taken in my brother's
name I've been listening to a lot of the
news today where it seems to be the
press who are generally saying that it
is linked to my brother okay there was
some questions were supposed to be
answered they weren't answered therefore
there was a domino effect from that
which we don't condone at all
would you take the opportunity now to
speak to people in Tottenham what would
you say to them just predict for the
next couple of nights what would you say
to people of Surrey I know people are
frustrated they're angry out there at
the moment I would say please try to
hold it down please don't make this very
long my brother's life above all was a
good man